I'm Bob Sutton. I'm an organizational
psychologist I've been at the Stanford
engineering school for more than 35 years studied
all sorts of elements of leading innovation. How I
see myself as at that sort of uncomfortable
intersection between the rigor of academia
and what it takes to get things done in the real
world. So in "Leading Innovation" I'm bringing you
ideas at the intersection between three things.
First of all the best research we could find
about what leaders do to promote innovation
things like creating constructive conflict
psychological safety getting people to come up
with a wide range of ideas and then to pick the
best. The second part is to give you some of
the best case studies we can find from Apple,
IDEO, Pixar, Intel so you can learn from
the best practices and avoid the worst.
And then finally we bring you veteran executives
so you can learn from Perry Klebahn who invented
the modern snowshoe now sort of a master
innovation teacher. "Innovation is something that
the uncertainty can drive fear." Carl Liebert was
CEO of the largest residential real estate company
"change before you have to change once you get
behind it's really difficult to spend enough
money to catch up." Sylvia Acevedo her last job
was CEO of the girl scouts before that she was
a rocket scientist a tech executive. "When people
didn't look for somebody like me I would focus on
the skills and then that allowed me in." Finally
the remarkable and imaginative venture capitalist,
Michael Dearing. "You have to tell a story you
have to be great at making sense of the complex
reality for people." So in "Leading Innovation" by
bringing you through a tour of those three things
punctuated by all sorts of different exercises is
to help you understand the cases and companies you
can learn from the people I hope who can inspire
you and always we go back to what we think is the
best evidence about what good leaders do and how
they design their teams and their organizations.